[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the top 10 facts you probably
didn't know about azúcar midoriya aka
Deku the protagonist of my hero academia
Deku is the lovable crybaby we follow as
he trains desperately and works towards
his dream of becoming the greatest hero
we get to watch his journey from quark
less and hopeless cry-baby to the
strongest hero and that's really what I
love about this show its underlying
optimism it's view that anyone can make
their dreams come true if they are
willing to work tirelessly and put their
blood sweat and tears into it if a quark
less wimp can become the greatest hero
then you the viewer can make your dreams
come true as well if you're willing to
hustle that is today I'm going to be
telling you about some interesting facts
about this inspirational figure that you
probably don't know facts which will
hopefully add to your appreciation of
our plain-looking protagonist if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe for
more videos like this one and if you
want to see more my hero academia or
fact videos make sure to Detroit smash
that like button to let me know also
feel free to drop any suggestions you
have in the comment section and it may
just be the next video you see all right
now without any further ado let's do
this number one let's start with some
basic information about deku deku is 166
centimeters tall or 5 foot 5 inches
which seems kind of short for a
superhero but to put things in
perspective Levi's humanity strongest
and kulit soldier from attack on Titan
is only 5 foot 3 so that's definitely
not going to hold Deku back however
since that ku is still young he's
probably still got a fair bit of growing
to do I wouldn't be surprised if he
turned out to be as tall and buff as all
might himself Deku was born on July 15th
a birthday he shares was Ichigo from
Bleach another Shonen manga and anime
that was extremely popular at its peak
now let's just hope that fellow Ana
tuber super eyepatch rule doesn't have
to make a fall of my hero academia video
in the future
number 2 dec was 14 years old when the
series first start and he is currently
16 years old in the manga
according to an interview with the
mangaka Kohei horikoshi
we can also expect a bigger time-skip in
the future as we've seen in other Shonen
anime like Dragonball Naruto and
one-piece hoodie course she was always
interested in hero origin stories which
is part of the reason that my hero
academia is located in a school setting
we'll get to the other reason later
however he doesn't want to just talk
about the origin story
he has already thought about what these
UA students would be like as pro heroes
he would be excited to do a second part
something like Naruto Shippuden for my
hero academia and according to horikoshi
we can expect a darker more mature tone
for this continuation number three is
Akuma Doria was originally an adult
salesman called jack midoriya he was the
main character of a one-shot manga
called my hero that horikoshi wrote
because of Jack's feeble body
he couldn't hope to get a hero license
so he joined the hero weapon
manufacturing company because that was
the only way he could get his hands on
the weapons he would need to be a hero
and fight evildoers Jack is a mixture of
Deku and all night he is hopeful and
hardworking like Deku but he also coughs
a blood regularly like all my does in
his feeble form this is a great story
and I strongly recommend that you check
it out the main reason horikoshi chose
to switch the main character's age and
the setting is because he really wanted
to have a successful manga Inchon and
jump but shounen jump readers usually
between 13 and 17 years old would have
had a hard time relating to an adult
protagonist number 4 the character of
yuzu kuma Doria and his story was very
much the result of Hiroko she his mood
and mental state after the cancellation
of one of his previous manga you see my
hero academia was not horikoshi his
first work to be publishing shown and
drum he had two other works published
previously including Omega Doki Zoo and
barrage the latter having a very short
run due to its lack of popularity at
this point but eco she was very
depressed and doubting whether or not he
had what it took to be a successful
manga he was starting to think that he
just wasn't born with the talent needed
to be among Kaka much like a zoo cool
wasn't born what the quirk needed to be
a hero so what he caught she decided to
put things he liked
on previous works into his new manga
which would be filled with optimism to
help himself get over his own depression
he really liked working on the one-shot
my hero so he decided to bring back the
main character and the world in many
ways
you can see horikoshi situation
reflected in deku deku also doubts
himself he wants to be a hero so bad he
is willing to work so hard but he
doesn't have a natural quirk that would
allow for this dream to come true and
yet he doesn't want to give up on his
dream and eventually runs into all my
who gives him his own course and all of
a sudden Deku comes to realize that he
can be the greatest hero if he is
willing to hustle his butt off similarly
Shonen drum game hero cost you another
chance and lo and behold my hero
academia turned out to be a smash hit
pun intended I hope that you guys like
me can draw inspiration from both Deku
story and hero coffee story whether you
want to be the Pirate King the Hokage
the greatest hero or even a full-time
youtuber as the immortal bard mmm once
said you can do anything you set your
mind to man I don't know how to turn
into a motivational speech but anyways
let's get back to the fact number 5
after everything we learned so far it
may not surprise you that that ku came
first place in the first line here
academia popularity poll it may seem
common sense that the main character
will come in first place but this is not
always the case for example Levi always
comes in first place rather than Aaron
in attack on Titan popularity polls and
when you're competing with as many
awesome characters as there are in my
hero academia deck whose achievement is
all the more impressive however he did
drop one spot in the second popularity
poll believe it or not for you anime
only fans he was replaced by a very own
bully Bakugan who happens to get some
great characterization later on in the
series let me know who your absolute
favorite character is in the comments
section below
number six is Akuma Doria also known as
student number 18 in class 1a ranks 4th
in his class when it comes to grades
unlike many shown and protagonists think
Naruto and Goku especially Goku mediodía
is very intelligent and this is shown
outside of the classroom even more so
than inside of the classroom midoriya is
not
an ask minded guy who can't wait to rush
into his next fight as long as we have
known him he has been taking physical
and mental notes of every hero student
and villain he comes across his mind is
always active whether he's analyzing
people's moves and coming up with
strategies to use against them in the
future or whether he is desperately
trying to think his way out of a
difficult situation in my opinion this
is a refreshing change to see in a
shounen manga as protagonist and it's
one of the things I really like about my
hero academia number 7 is Akuma Doria is
constantly said to be plain looking in
the series and he'd of course she
thought he was - which is why when he
was redesigning the adult midoriya into
teenage midoriya he tried to make him
look cooler he was going to have his
hair cover one of his eyes kind of like
Sanji from one piece but on Deku it just
looked like he was begging for a haircut
eventually he of course she decided that
the planar Deku looked the better and I
think that he made the right decision
the fact that he's so plain to begin
with makes his road to becoming the
greatest hero all the more epic number
eight as I mentioned in every quirk from
class 1-a explained and every word from
class 1 be explained you know Co she is
very careful and purposeful when it
comes to choosing names for his
characters the names usually reflect the
character's appearance personality and
or quirk music whose name is no
exception
he's Akuma daughter's name includes the
kanji for green for valley for coming
from a specific place and for long ago
midoriya means green and Japanese and it
also happens to be the color of Decker's
eyes hair and hero costumes I for one
would be very confused if it didn't turn
out to be his favorite color also when
you say someone's green it means that
they are a beginner or someone who is
inexperienced which definitely applies
to Dec these are just some of the ways
in which is Akuma dorias character is
reflected in his name number 9 now let's
turn to use approve nickname deku deku
is actually an alternate reading of the
country for Zuko and it means useless or
someone who can't achieve anything
obviously we know that baku go started
calling him this when they were still
kids in order to insult him however
roodaka
flips the meaning of the nickname
completely she finds it to be inspiring
because in Japanese
Gotha never give up vibe or a feeling of
I can do it there are some changes in
the Funimation dub because although
these reasons work in Japanese both
battle goals and salt and Oh Dada cos
interpretation when it makes sense to
most English speakers so they made Deku
an abbreviation for defenseless easy
cool taking the de from the beginning of
defenseless and that K u from the ending
of azubu in contrast Veronica likes the
name because she thinks it would make a
great hero name and that it sounds kind
of cute immediately midoriya responds
sec who it is I personally like the
Japanese version more but I get that it
might have been a bit jarring if they
try to explain Japanese Kanji in the
dump then eventually you could choose as
a KU as as hero name which reminds me of
how Tyrion and Jon Snow from Game of
Thrones embrace insulting names and wear
them as armor so they can never be used
to hurt them and bonus back deck was
also a race from The Legend of Zelda who
are seen as weak but like Eva cool they
can hit pretty hard number 10 now let's
talk about that goose quark one for all
so far every single known user of one
for all has had his or her correlating
user number in their name in other words
the seventh user of the quark was called
Nana which is Japanese for the number
seven all might aka Toshi nori yagi is
the eighth user and he has the kanji for
eighth in his name finally use Ooka
Midori ax has qu in his name which can
refer to the number nine in Japanese so
it almost seems like Deku was destined
to inherit the power from the very
beginning and there it is guys top ten
facts you probably didn't know about
that group there are some other
interesting facts like the fact that
Deku sweat glands are always in
overdrive that his favorite food is
katsu Don and so on but I think we
covered the most important one as always
thank you so much for watching guys if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
Detroit smash that like button I know a
lot of you have been accidentally
breaking your phones and tablets in this
way you've been letting us know in the
comments but you know what that's a
small price to pay for all my levels of
Awesomeness if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe for more my hero
academia videos like this one and until
next time
see
yeah space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]